which
the title of this talk is certificate
games I'm anupa sunny and this is a
joint work with Sarah chakraborty anagar
Sophie LeBlanc and rajat mittal
in this talk we will look at some
complexity measures of Boolean functions
in particular we consider a two player
game where the players are not allowed
to communicate
based on the probability of winning this
game on a function we introduce a
complexity measure for this function
we will compare this new measure with
existing complexity measures and see how
it fits in in the landscape of
complexity measures
let me first introduce the game
we have a Boolean function f which takes
an N bit string as input and Maps it to
0 or 1.
the player's Alice and Bob are not
allowed to communicate and this is
illustrated by placing a wall between
them
Alice gets his input X which is mapped
to 0 by the function and Bob gets his
input Y which is mapped to 1 by the
function
now Alice has to produce an index I
between 1 and n as her output and Bob
has to produce an index J
they win this game which we call a
certificate game if the indices they
produce this outputs match that is I is
equal to J and their inputs differ at
this index that is x i is not equal to y
i
note that this is the zero communication
gain that is the players are not allowed
to communicate
based on the certificate game that we
introduced we Define the certificate
game complexity measure as the inverse
of the winning probability for the best
strategy and the worst case input pair
we consider four variants of this
complexity measure based on the
strategies that the players are allowed
to use
the first of these is the CG measure
where each of the players has access to
their private sources of randomness
the second is the CG Pub measure where
the players can use a shared source of
randomness
next we have the CG star measure where
the players say I love to use shared
entanglement and lastly we have the
cgnis measure in which they can use any
non-signaling strategy that is analysis
strategy has to be independent of Bob's
input and Bob's strategy has to be
independent of Alice's input
since any private Randomness strategy
can be simulated using shared Randomness
and since shared Randomness can be
simulated using shared entanglement and
non-signaling strategies subsume all of
these we have this string of
inequalities as shown here
certificate games are related to various
Concepts that have appeared in the
literature they are similar to Castro
vectors in games except the players are
not allowed to communicate here
they are also related to non-local games
but the objective function is different
here
so why do we consider CG measures
the most important reason is that when
we consider Its Behavior with respect to
other measures it fits in nicely in the
landscape of complexity measures
here I have this diagram which
illustrates the relations between some
of the known complexity measures and the
newly introduced CG measures in red
boxes
an arrow from A to B indicates that a is
asymptotically larger than b
the certificate game measures are easier
to bound above due to their game
formulation and on the other hand
certain variants such as the public
Randomness variant CG Pub and the
non-signaling variant cgns have dual
formulations in terms of linear programs
which help give lower bounds
the outline for the rest of the talk is
the following we will focus on relating
certificate games to well-known
complexity measures the definitions for
these measures are included in the
slides for completeness but I will skip
through them due to time constraints
if you would like to recall any of these
definitions kindly pause and proceed
we will begin with an upper bound on the
CG measures with respect to the well
studied certificate complexity
as a warm exercise we show that the
private Randomness variant CG is at most
a product of zero certificate complexity
and one certificate complexity
a useful property of zero certificates
and one certificates is that any zero
certificate and one certificate should
intersect at some position that is there
should be an index which is assigned
conflicting values by the two
certificates
let CX be a smallest size 0 certificate
for x and let's see if I be a smallest
size one certificate for y
let us consider the following protocol
using private randomness
now Alice is given an input x with the
function value 0 by the verifier and Bob
gets y with the function value 1. they
send their outputs to the verifier who
checks if their outputs satisfy the
winning condition or not
now Alice and Bob take their respective
certificates and randomly pick an index
that is assigned a value
now when do they win if they use this
strategy
they will when they pick an index common
to both the certificates and that is
assigned conflicting values with what
probability does this happen
now Allah speaks this common index with
probability at least 1 over c0 and Bob
picks the common index with probability
at least 1 over C1
that's the probability that their
outputs match and this correct is at
least 1 over C 0 times C1
the private Randomness variant CG is at
most the inverse of the winning
probability which is bounded above by
the product of C 0 and C1
note that this bound is tight for
instance we have the parity function
whose zero certificate complexity and
one certificate complexity are n and we
can show that CG of the parity function
is N squared
now can share Randomness help
what we have so far is that the private
Randomness variant CG is at most the
product of zero certificate complexity
and one certificate complexity
it is straightforward to see that
the public Randomness variant is always
bounded above by n
for instance we could sample a random
index T using shared Randomness and both
Alice and Bob output the index t
with probability at least 1 over n this
is an index where their inputs differ
and they win
but can they do better with shared
Randomness we will focus on this in the
next few slides
we will start with an example of the
tribes function to illustrate the power
of shared Randomness we will generalize
this protocol to get a better upper
bound on the public Randomness variant
of CD Pub
in particular we show that
CJ Pub is at most certificate complexity
which is the maximum of zero certificate
complexity and one certificate
complexity
let us now come to the tribes function
it is defined as a composition of the
odd function on square root n Bits with
the and function on square root and bits
in other words we can think of the input
as being divided into root and blocks of
size root in each
to each of these blocks the and function
is applied and their outputs are sent to
the or function
now according to our setup Alice gets an
input X which is evaluated to 0 by the
tribes function what does such an input
look like
since the output is 0 the input to the
or function should be all zeros
since each of these input bits is the
output of an and function applied on a
block there must be at least one zero in
each of these blocks
now Alice does the following for each
block I she picks an index AI where the
input bit is zero that is X of I comma
AI is 0.
for Simplicity we consider the special
case where all of the AI is chosen by
Alice are distinct
does Alice has a bunch of AIS from A1 up
to a root n which are all distinct now
what does Bob's input look like
Bob has an input Y which evaluates to
one this means that there is an input
bit to the or function which is 1.
since this input bit is the output of an
and function the corresponding input
block should be all once this Bob has at
least one block which is only once
pop picks one such block and calls it P
since every position in Bob's Block B is
1 and since Alice has a 0 in each block
the index B comma a b should have a zero
in analysis input and a 1 in Bob's input
if Alice and Bob are both able to
identify this position they win the
certificate game
now let us look at the following
protocol which uses shared randomness
Alice and Bob pick an index T between 1
and N using shared randomness
Bob knows that his output must come from
within his Block B and so he outputs B
comma T
now Alice searches all of her AIS for an
AI which is equal to T and she outputs I
comma t
now both of them output B comma a b if
the randomly chosen T is equal to a b
that is when T is equal to the index
where Alice has a 0 in the beat block
but what probability does this happen
since T is chosen randomly T equals a b
with probability 1 over square root n so
both of them output B comma a b with
probability
Omega of 1 over root 10.
we have considered a special case where
all of the AIS chosen by Alice are
distinct we will see that we can relax
this constraint using hash functions
when we generalize this protocol to all
functions
now what we have seen so far is that the
public randomness
helps in the tribes function
it is easy to check that the zero
certificate complexity and one
certificate complexity of this function
are Wooten
using our upper Bound for the private
Randomness variant we have CG of tribes
to be at most n
a matching lower bound also exists which
gives CG of tribes to be Theta of n
we have seen that public Randomness
gives you a significant advantage that
is CJ Pub of tribes is over fruitin and
a matching lower bot also exists
using similar ideas we will show that CG
pop of a function is asymptotically at
most certificate complexity
firstly let us pick a set s of size
certificate complexity of f
let's see X and c y be smallest size
certificates for X and Y respectively
Now using shared Randomness we select a
random hash function H that Maps the set
of all indices to the set s
we also select a random element Z from
the set s using shared randomness
now Alice looks at the set of indices
that are assigned values in her
certificate and she checks if any of
those indices are mapped to Z by the
hash function h
she outputs one such index randomly
Bob does the same with his certificate
now let I star B and index that is
common to both the certificates and is
assigned conflicting values by them
what is the probability that both and
Alice output I stop
for this two events must happen
the first is that age Maps I start to Z
and the second is that no other index in
their certificates is mapped to set
since H is a random hash function the
first event happens with probability 1
over size of s that is 1 over
certificate complexity of f
we can also show with constant
probability that no other index is
mapped to Z
this shows that CG pop of a function is
at most its certificate complexity
an argument with weights gives that CJ
Pub is bounded above by expectational
certificate complexity which is a
smaller measure than certificate
complexity
we will now move on to another
complexity measure called the randomized
query complexity and see how CG pop is
related to it
here is the definition for the query
complexity measure
we will now show that CG pop-up function
is at most randomized query complexity
in a decision tree let us consider a
path that leads to a leaf labeled one
and a path that leads to a late label 0.
any two such paths must necessarily
diverge
here they diverge at the node X2 that is
any two inputs that lead to these paths
must differ at the second bit
the players win the certificate game if
they are able to identify this node
using shared Randomness Alice and Bob
sampled a deterministic decision tree
according to the probability
distribution given by the optimal
randomized decision tree
now the probability that this decision
tree is wrong on X is at most 1 by 3 and
the probability that it is wrong on Y is
Atmos 1 by 3. this means that the
probability that it is wrong on either
of them is Atmos 2 by 3 and thus with
probability at least 1 by 3 the sample
decision tree is correct on both X and Y
so using shared Randomness I'll listen
Bob sample a level T
between 1 and the randomized query
complexity of the function
they output the tth index queried by the
decision Tree on their respective inputs
now with probability at least one over
rff T corresponds to the node whether
paths diverge since CG pop is at most
the inverse of the probability that the
outputs of the players match and are
correct we have that CG Pub is at most
rff
foreign
it is natural to ask if the quantum
variant of the certificate gains CG star
is at most the quantum query complexity
Q of f however this is not the case as
the or function has quantum theory
complexity Theta of root n we shall see
in the next few slides that CG Pub of
the or function is Theta of n
we will now show a lower bound on the
smallest certificate games mesha we
consider namely the cgns measure we will
start with an example and then show a
general lower Bound in terms of another
complexity measure called the fractional
certificate complexity
but first let me formally Define cgns
strategies
we will use PFI given X Y to denote the
probability that Alice on input X
outputs I when Bob has input pi and
similarly we Define PF J given x y
we say that the probability distribution
P corresponds to a non-signaling
strategy if Alice's output does not
depend on Bob's input and vice versa
that is the probability that Alice on
input X outputs I when Bob has input Y
is the same as the probability that
Alice on input X outputs I when Bob's
input is different and similarly for Bob
they will show that cgnness of the or
function is at least n
we prove this by contradiction
let us assume that the winning
probability of the cgns gain is greater
than 1 by n
this will imply that the players can
send information without communication
now suppose Bob wants to send a number
between 1 and L Alice choices the all
zero string as her input
Bob thinks this picks the string with
zeros everywhere except that the ith
place where it is 1
they can now run the zero communication
game order of end times and take the
majority output
Alice now learns some non-trivial
information about the number I that Bob
wanted to send but this would violate
the non-signaling principle thus by
contradiction we have the cgn is
therefore is at least n
we will now see that cjns is bounded
below by fractional certificate
complexity which is a measure for which
multiple formulations have appeared in
the literature
the proof can be sketched as follows let
P be the probability distribution given
by an optimal cgns strategy
since p is non-signaling we can take
marginal distributions to be PFI given X
since they are independent of the other
player's input y
our idea would be to use the probability
distribution P to construct weights vxis
which are feasible solutions for the
fractional certificate complexity linear
program
we will use the following important
properties or inequalities in our proof
the first is that the probability that
Alice outputs are correct index I is at
least the probability that both of them
output a correct index I
the second is that if Delta is equal to
1 over c g n s of f the probability that
both output are correct index I is
greater than or equal to Delta
now we will construct weights for FC
using p we choose vxis to be PFI given X
scale by 1 over Delta for all X and for
all I
using the inequalities given earlier we
can easily show that this is a feasible
solution we now have that cgns is at
least FC
we will now consider the single bit
versions of certificate games which are
played on restricted inputs here are the
definitions for the complexity measures
sensitivity and spectral sensitivity
which we will show are related to the
single bit versions of certificate game
complexity measures
single bit versions of certificate games
are played on restricted inputs X and Y
which have different function values and
have a Hamming distance one between them
we show that the public Randomness
variant characterizes sensitivity
exactly and
sorry the public Randomness variant
characterizes the sensitivity exactly
and the private Randomness variant is
equal to the square of the spectral
sensitivity
now we bring back the diagram which
illustrates the relations that we have
discussed in this talk and more
some of the important open questions are
the following can we come up with a
better upper Bound for CJ Pub in terms
of the single bit version of CG Pub in
particular is CG pub at most square of
CG pub1
a positive answer to this would resolve
the quadratic sensitivity block
sensitivity conjecture
they could also ask if we can come up
with a better upper bound on the Zero
error and device query complexity r0 of
f in terms of the square of CG Pub
thank you